the well ordering principle is one of
those facts in mathematics that's so
obvious that you hardly notice it and
the objective of this brief introduction
is to call your attention to it we've
actually used it already and in
subsequent segments of this presentation
we'll show lots of applications of it
so here's a statement of the well
ordering principle every non-empty set
of non-negative integers has a least
element now this is probably familiar
maybe you hadn't even thought about it
but now that I mentioned it I expect
it's a familiar idea and it's pretty
obvious too if you think about it for a
minute here's a way to think about it
given a non-empty set of integers you
could ask is zero the least element in
it well if it is then you're done then
you could say is one the least element
in it and if it is you're done and if it
isn't you could say to is is to the
least element and so on given that it's
not empty eventually you're going to hit
the least element so if it wasn't
obvious before there's something of a
hand waving proof of it but I want to
get you to think about this well
ordering principle a little bit because
it's not if there are some technical
parts of it that matter so
for example suppose I replaced
non-negative integers by non-negative
rationals and I asked does every set
non-empty set of non-negative rationals
have a least element well there is a
least non negative rational namely zero
but not every non-negative set of
rationals has a least element I'll let
you think of an example another variant
is when instead of talking about the
non-negative integers I just talk about
all the integers is there at least
integer well no obviously because minus
one is not the least and minus two is
not the least and there isn't any least
integer we take for granted the well
ordering principle just all the time if
I asked you what was the youngest age of
an MIT graduate well you wouldn't for a
moment wonder whether there was a
youngest age and if I asked you for the
smallest number of neurons in any animal
you wouldn't wonder
whether there was there wasn't a
smallest number of neurons we may not
know what it is but there's surely a
smallest number of neurons because
neurons are non-negative integers and
finally if I asked you what was the
smallest number of US coins that could
make a dollar 17 again we don't have to
worry about existence because the well
ordering principle knocks that off
immediately now for the remainder of
this hook I'm going to be talking about
the non-negative integers always unless
I explicitly say otherwise so I'm just
going to use the word number to mean
non-negative integer there's a standard
mathematical symbol that we use to
denote that non-negative integers it's
that letter n at the top of the slide
with a double with a diagonal double bar
these are sometimes called the natural
numbers but I've never been able to
understand or figure out whether zero is
natural or not so we don't use that
phrase we zero is included in n the
non-negative integers and that's what we
call them in this class
now I want to point out that we've
actually used the well ordering
principle already without maybe not
noticing it even in the proof that the
square root of two was not rational that
proof began by saying suppose the square
root of two was rational that is it was
a quotient of integers M over N and the
remark was that you can always express a
fraction like that in lowest terms more
precisely you can always find positive
numbers m and n without common factors
such that the square root of two equals
M over N if there's any fraction equal
to the square root of 2a then there's a
lowest terms fraction M over N with no
common factors
so now we can use well ordering to come
up with a simple and and hopefully very
clear and convincing argument for why
every fraction can be expressed in
lowest terms in particular let's look at
numbers m and n such that the square
root of 2 is equal to M and M over N
that fraction and let's just choose the
smallest numerator that works try to
find the smallest numerator M such that
square root of 2 is equal to M over N
well I claim that that fraction which
uses the small as possible numerator has
got to be in lowest terms because
suppose that m and n had a common factor
C that was greater than 1
a real common factor then you could
replace M over N by M over C the
numerator is a smaller numerator that's
still an integer and over C with the
denominator is still an integer and we
have a numerator if it's smaller than M
contradicting the way that we chose M in
the first place
diction of course implies that M&N have
no common factors and therefore has
claimed M over N is in lowest terms
and of course wait I formulated this was
for our application of the fraction that
was equal to the square root of 2 but
this proof actually shows that any
rational number any fraction can be
expressed in lowest terms